a 2
nos habéis mandado miles de mensajes
pidiéndonos que hablemos sobre las
protestas de nicaragua las más violentas
que ha sufrido este país en los últimos
30 años donde ya varias personas han
perdido la vida y sí ya sé lo que me
vais a decir fonseca llevamos casi un
año pidiendo os que habléis de cataluña
y seguimos esperando y vale tenéis razón
y ese vídeo va a llegar muy pronto de
hecho ya estamos editando lo pero el
caso de nicaragua es especialmente
urgente en este país casi todos los
medios de comunicación están controlados
por el presidente daniel ortega y su
familia es más el gobierno ha censurado
la retransmisión de las protestas en
todas las televisiones nacionales en
otras palabras que prácticamente el
único medio de comunicación por el que
los nicaragüenses pueden conocer lo que
está pasando en su propio país es este
youtube
bueno y por supuesto facebook y twitter
también y por eso casi todas las fuentes
de información que hemos usado para este
vídeo vienen de las fotos y documentos
que nos habéis enviado todos
amigos de visual político que vivís en
nicaragua muchas gracias por vuestra
ayuda y sin más rodeos vamos a contaros
qué diablos está ocurriendo en nicaragua
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hasta las pasadas semanas nicaragua
estaba considerado como el país más
seguro de toda latinoamérica y a la vez
el segundo más pobre tal cual como lo
oís lo cierto es que nicaragua es un
país lleno de contradicciones
[Música]
su presidente daniel ortega presume de
sus raíces marxistas pero a la vez se
define como católico practicante y de
hecho ha prohibido el aborto en su país
sin embargo pese a tener unas
convicciones morales tan intachable es
daniela ortega tiene un juicio abierto
por haber abusado nada menos que de su
hijastra pero hay una cosa que le
tenemos que reconocer es un hombre
auténticamente familiar de hecho sabéis
quién es la vicepresidenta de nicaragua
exacto su mujer que se llama rosario
murillo
[Música]
en definitiva que el presidente de
nicaragua es todo un angelito sin
embargo lleva gobernando el país desde
el año 2007 con un apoyo popular que no
baja del 60% pero no sólo eso si algo le
tenemos que reconocer a daniel ortega
son sus habilidades diplomáticas y estoy
hablando totalmente en serio
nicaragua es uno de los pocos países del
mundo que tiene buenas relaciones con
venezuela irán y rusia y a la vez con
eeuu tal cual como lo oís muchos
antiguos compañeros del partido de
ortega el frente sandinista le acusan de
ser un vendido al capitalismo de hecho
aunque nicaragua sea un país tan pobre
es también uno de los más estables de la
zona con un crecimiento promedio de más
del 46 por ciento
es más la población que vive bajo el
umbral de la pobreza se recorta año tras
año no sólo eso mientras otros países de
la zona como méxico o guatemala sufre en
un auténtico éxodo de ciudadanos que se
marcha en eeuu
los nicaragüenses parecen estar más o
menos satisfechos con su situación hasta
ahora la gota que ha colmado la
paciencia de muchos ciudadanos ha sido
la reforma de las pensiones el gobierno
ha recortado las jubilaciones a la vez
que ha subido las cotizaciones a la
seguridad social como os podéis imaginar
este movimiento no ha gustado ni a los
empresarios ni a los trabajadores
y así es como se han desatado las
mayores protestas contra el régimen de
daniel ortega estas protestas se han
tratado de reprimir con brutalidad
policial y encarcelamientos masivos ya
hay varias personas que han perdido la
vida en los enfrentamientos e incluso el
gobierno ha utilizado a sus propios
simpatizantes como fuerzas de choque
para frenar a los manifestantes
pero al menos por el momento ninguna de
estas medidas ha conseguido neutralizar
los movimientos de protesta así que
ahora la pregunta es por qué está
ocurriendo todo esto en este momento en
el que nicaragua no tiene ninguna crisis
económica estamos ante el fin del
régimen de daniel ortega el fin de la
nicaragua sandinista hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nicaragua sandinista los que veáis este
vídeo desde españa y tengáis más de 30
años reconoceréis esta canción al
instante se trata de nicaragua
sandinista uno de los primeros éxitos de
cortar
[Música]
lo cierto es que en los años 80
nicaragua se convirtió en todo un
símbolo de la lucha contra el imperio
estadounidense por aquellos años el
frente sandinista acababa de llegar al
poder tras décadas de dictadura de
extrema derecha
el frente sandinista es un partido que
se define como marxista leninista anti
imperialista yanqui pero que tiene algo
que os va a llamar la atención son
extremadamente religiosos durante esos
años muchos sectores de la iglesia
católica apoyaban sin lugar a dudas a
los sandinistas sí amigos de visual
político estoy hablando de la teología
de la liberación mensaje
auténtico y verdadero cristianismo y si
ese señor que veis en la pantalla es
daniel ortega por aquel entonces ortega
ya era el líder del frente sandinista y
el presidente del país como os podéis
imaginar en mitad de la guerra fría a
eeuu no estaba dispuesto a que nicaragua
se pasará al bando comunista así que él
por entonces presidente norteamericano
ronald reagan organizó una de las
operaciones políticas más polémicas de
la historia
por un lado se dedicó a venderle armas
al gobierno de irán que estaba en guerra
con el irak de sadam husein todo esto
por supuesto en secreto porque
oficialmente irán era un enemigo
declarado de eeuu después utilizó todo
el dinero que ganó con esta venta para
financiar a la llamada contra
nicaragüense que era un grupo de extrema
derecha que luchaba contra el gobierno
de daniel ortega hands week y negro aquí
estoy hablando de nicaragua un aliado
soviético en territorio americano que
está a dos horas de vuelo de nuestro
país pronuncio mejor nuestra propia
seguridad eeuu no puede permitir que la
unión soviética tenga una punta de lanza
en norteamérica como os podéis imaginar
cuando todo esto salió a la luz
corrieron ríos de tinta y de vinilo por
eso si os gustan los grupos de música de
los años 80 encontrareis montones de
referencias a la nicaragua sandinista
desde este tema de kortatu hasta el
disco sandinista de los clash y ahora os
preguntaréis
qué hizo daniel ortega cuando llegó al
gobierno pues en cierto modo podríamos
decir que fue el precursor de la
venezuela de maduro
por hacer un resumen el gobierno
sandinista se dedicó a nacionalizar
todas las empresas que estaban en manos
de los oligarcas locales y a financiar
todos los gastos pidiendo deudas a la
unión soviética e imprimiendo dinero
como si no existiera mañana el resultado
en el año 1986 cuando la revolución
sandinista llevaba poco más de un lustro
en el poder
nicaragua estaba sufriendo una de las
hiperinflaciones más salvajes de la
historia mundial en los peores momentos
del conflicto entre los líderes
sandinistas y los líderes rebeldes
apoyados por eeuu todos los
nicaragüenses tenían algo en común su
necesidad de dólares estadounidenses
para que os hagáis una idea los precios
en la divisa local el córdoba se
duplicaban cada 15 días esto significa
que si te tomabas una cerveza en un bar
y te costaba 10 córdobas volvías 4 meses
más tarde y te costaba 3 mil córdobas os
lo hemos dicho mil veces aquí en visual
político
lo peor que le puede pasar a un gobierno
es tener hiperinflación
[Música]
y por eso pese a que daniel ortega tenía
un enorme apoyo social incluyendo a
muchos sectores de la iglesia los
ciudadanos estaban en una situación
desesperada y muchos pensaréis pero si
la moneda local era tan débil porque no
cambiaban dólares pues simple y
llanamente porque cuando vives en un
país donde todo el mundo quiere dólares
es muy difícil encontrarlos los que
veáis este vídeo desde venezuela o
argentina ya sabéis a lo que me refiero
así que en el año 1990 nicaragua
estrenaba nueva divisa el córdoba de oro
y un nuevo gobierno totalmente distinto
durante los años 90 daniel ortega estuvo
ocupando el banquillo de la oposición
mientras tanto el país conseguía
recuperarse de la hiperinflación y
volver a esa situación de pobreza
combinada con cierta estabilidad es
decir los nicaragüenses seguían siendo
pobres pero al menos no perdían poder
adquisitivo cada semana ni tenían que
temer por su vida y con esta situación
de relativa tranquilidad llegamos al año
2006 año en el que se vuelven a celebrar
elecciones y vamos a ver qué es lo que
pasó
[Música]
de marxista a or tenista efectivamente
en el año 2006
ortega vuelve al gobierno pero esta vez
se trataba de un daniel ortega muy
distinto al que estábamos acostumbrados
por supuesto seguía perteneciendo al
frente sandinista pero tantos años en la
oposición le habían cambiado sus
principios
[Música]
[Aplausos]
daniel ortega ha dejado de ser un
partidario del marxismo leninismo y ha
pasado a ser un partidario de daniel
ortega ese es el problema
declaraciones de un militante del frente
sandinista por supuesto que esta nueva
versión de daniel ortega mantiene un
discurso socialista su gobierno
garantiza el acceso universal a la
educación y la sanidad y de hecho tanto
la tasa de escolarización como la
esperanza de vida han crecido en
nicaragua pero esas ansias por
nacionalizar todas las empresas que
había en el país se han sustituido por
un discurso mucho más moderado los
trabajadores
de la ciudad y el can
obreros campesinos
los productores
los emprendedores
los pequeños empresarios
los grandes empresarios toda la fuerza
económica y social del país
todo unido pero esperad un momento
porque todavía hay más hace 30 años
nicaragua era algo así como el enemigo
perfecto del 'tío sam' verdad pues bien
desde hace unos años
nicaragua ha firmado un pacto de libre
comercio con eeuu el cafta y colaboran
en operaciones contra el narcotráfico
para que os hagáis una idea el mercado
de la agricultura en eeuu está híper
protegido pero el chocolate y el café y
los plátanos nicaragüenses son la
excepción apenas tienen restricciones
para entrar en el mercado estadounidense
pero la cosa no termina aquí
[Música]
recordáis las zonas económicas
especiales os hemos hablado mil veces de
ellas se trata de una zona dentro de un
país en desarrollo donde hay pocos
impuestos y leyes más flexibles que
permiten atraer a las empresas
extranjeras pues bien
nicaragua también se ha puesto a las
pilas en este respecto esto que estáis
viendo es un anuncio del gobierno de
nicaragua para atraer a los inversores
internacionales si alguien está pensando
en invertir en nicaragua le animaría a
venir y hacerlo tendrá las mismas
ventajas que encontrarían muchos otros
lugares cercanos a eeuu población
bilingüe y bien educada por sorprendente
que parezca desde que ortega volvió al
poder
nicaragua se ha llenado de goal centers
de empresas de todo el mundo
mano de obra barata impuestos especiales
y lo más importante es el único país de
la zona sin guerrillas urbanas ni
violencia en las calles y os
preguntaréis pero qué le ha pasado a
daniel ortega ha tenido una especie de
revelación por su
esto que no lo que pasa es que se ha
dado cuenta de que es más fácil
mantenerse en el poder cuando la
economía va razonablemente bien
y prueba de ello es que elección tras
elección ortega gana con porcentajes
superiores al 60% por supuesto que hay
toda clase de fraudes electorales sin
embargo habría que ser muy tonto para
pensar que ortega no tiene apoyo popular
pero no sólo eso ha descubierto que si
las finanzas de tu país van bien tú
controlas el gobierno con mano de hierro
tus finanzas personales también van muy
pero que muy bien
el presidente daniel ortega ha nombrado
a su esposa hijos cargos claves del
estado mientras la familia más una
fortuna gracias al petróleo de venezuela
mientras tanto su gobierno ha invertido
buena parte de ese dinero en evitar que
nadie le haga sombra prácticamente todos
los medios de comunicación en nicaragua
son propiedad del gobierno o de algún
familiar de daniel ortega y la nueva ley
de redes sociales que se ha empezado a
debatir en el parlamento en marzo de
2018 sería un intento de crear
mecanismos legales para censurar y
perseguir a activistas opositores en
redes sociales sin embargo las protestas
han empezado por una razón totalmente
distinta ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
y protestan en nicaragua la sabiduría
popular dice que las revoluciones
ocurren cuando un país está en crisis
verdad error craso error en realidad las
revoluciones ocurren cuando un país está
pasando por un mal momento y empieza de
repente a crecer
[Música]
porque porque si no hay nadie a tu
alrededor que conduzca un bmw no hay bmw
es a los que envidian me entendéis bien
pues bien de repente los nicaragüenses
están viendo como una nueva élite
surgida alrededor de la figura de daniel
ortega se está haciendo rica sí claro
todo el país está creciendo
económicamente pero algunos están
creciendo más rápido que otros y habría
que ser muy tonto para pensar esa nueva
clase alta nicaragüense ha llegado donde
está por méritos propios
todo esto es lo que llamamos un momento
populista una ventana de oportunidad
para que pueda darse un cambio de
gobierno es algo así como llenar una
habitación de gas basta con que alguien
encienda un mechero para que todo
explote y en este caso la llama ha sido
ésta
la polémica ley del instituto nacional
de la seguridad social ya es ley en la
república en resumen el gobierno ha
decidido bajar las pensiones y subir las
cotizaciones empresarios trabajadores y
estudiantes han salido a la calle como
si llevaran años esperándolo y el
gobierno se ve completamente superado
por la situación prueba de ello es que
han obligado a las televisiones
nicaragüenses a que dejen de
retransmitir las protestas
[Música]
sin embargo nada de esto ha evitado que
haya protestas por todo nicaragua y no
sólo en managua la capital sino también
en todas las ciudades de alrededor e
incluso en los pequeños municipios
muchos nos habéis escrito desde la
universidad central de nicaragua donde
hay miles de estudiantes que llevan días
concentrados en barricadas por lo que
nos contáis muchos simpatizantes se
encargan de llevar comida y botellas de
agua a los manifestantes pero después la
policía llega e incauta los víveres y
aunque no las vamos a mostrar tenemos
imágenes de gente gravemente herida por
los antidisturbios se trata de una
auténtica batalla campal en lo que hasta
hace poco era el país más pacífico de
latinoamérica
la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo
ahora es este el fin del régimen de
daniel ortega y como siempre decimos en
visual político en política y economía
no se pueden hacer predicciones que haya
mucha gente protestando no significa que
pueden cambiar un gobierno de entrada
todavía no sabemos si todos los
manifestantes comparten alguna idea o
algún líder pero en base a lo que nos
estáis contando diría que las barricadas
se están llenando con gente de todo tipo
por un lado tenemos a facciones
liberales que exigen un giro de 180
grados en la política del país pero
también hay muchos sandinistas radicales
que se sienten traicionados por daniela
ortega
[Música]
fin eso de las zonas económicas
especiales y la inversión extranjera no
suena muy marxista leninista que digamos
en otras palabras que por el momento no
hay mucha organización ni mucho menos un
líder que aglutina todo ese descontento
popular y sin eso es muy difícil ser una
alternativa real al poder establecido
pero esto no deja de ser mi análisis
personal y ahora turno para vosotros y
creéis que va a pasar de verdad creéis
que daniel ortega tiene los días
contados o nos queda sandinismo para
rato podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis que publicamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros a
visual político para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like
compartirlo con vuestros amigos y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]